[Musique]
bonjour à vous tous bonjour j mee
bonjour federica bonjour jean marie
clovis bonjour bertren carouge et
bonjour aux auditeurs donc de martinique
1ère vous êtes le président désormais
d'honneur de l'aef est ni martinique
alors là effet nice et la fédération
nationale des infirmières et infirmiers
libéraux 1
quand même vous intéresser
particulièrement syndicats cette
catégorie d'infirmier alors là fait ni
qui est présenté comme le premier
syndicat de cette catégorie
professionnelle
on va peut-être y revenir jean marie
clovis mais quelques mots pour commencer
sur vous vous avez été longtemps donc à
la gouverne de cet organisme de ce
syndicat en martinique et puis vous
passez la main d'où cette fonction de
président d'honneur en maintenant vous
passez la main progressivement mais tout
de même une nouvelle présidente vient
d'être élu oui en effet c'est vrai que
j'ai présidé donc le syndicat pendant
une vingtaine d'années donc à l'origine
aussi de la création du syndicat
nous avons participé au développement de
ce mode d'exercice en libérer à la
martinique est désormais c'est maryline
dubois qui préside le syndicat
martinique hier la fédération nationale
des infirmiers
voilà bon alors manifestement vous ne
désintéressé pas complètement quand même
peut-être encore de cette affaire là et
donc vous avez préparé
vous avez préparé l'organisation d'un
5ème séminaire de la fanny martinique à
5e séminaire donc qui commence
aujourd'hui qui va se dérouler durant
deux jours et dont le thème est prendre
le virage ambulatoire tout en prenant
soin de soi alors parlons d'abord de ce
concept de virage ambulatoire qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
alors c'est vrai que pour nous c'est
quelque chose de nos concepts nouveaux
c'est à dire qui est né donc depuis fin
2015 début 2016 parce que d'une manière
générale en france
williams a décidé donc de changer
d'orientation et de mettre l'accent
beaucoup plus sur la prévention et nous
sommes aperçus au moment de la sortie
aux différents décrets lois et c'est que
le secteur libéral infirmiers qui est
pourtant à la base donc de la prévention
puisque nous intervenant au domicile
avait été de nos points de vue oublie
notre cette raison que nous avons tenu à
mettre l'accent
ici à la martinique pour qu'ils
apprennent conscience aux infirmiers
libéraux que nous avions un rôle très
important et qu'il fallait agir très tôt
et l'avenir nous a donné enfin raison
puisqu'on constate qu'effectivement les
choses ont avancé depuis
pour nous alors la part des infirmiers
libéraux par rapport aux infirmiers qui
travaillent dans le service public de
dans la santé publique de la santé
publique
qu'allait-il qualitel plutôt en
martinique je veux dire voilà
aujourd'hui même si les chiffres ne sont
pas exacts mais il faut compter environ
3000 infirmiers à la martinique et nous
sommes environ 1100 sadi un tiers de la
profession exerce aujourd'hui un secteur
libre c'est beaucoup
d'accord c'est beaucoup justement c'est
pour ça je voulais insister là dessus et
donc c'est important de prendre
dites-vous ce virage ambulatoire et
c'est à dire quand on parle
l'ambulatoire en fait c'est des
infirmiers libéraux qui vont soigner les
personnes ne soient à leur domicile ou
dans les ehpad s'il s'agit de personnes
de seniors combat c'est à dire c'est
d'intervenir le plus tôt possible et
lorsque la maladie est déjà installé
éviter les complications et là
évidemment c'est ça se passe ça se passe
au domicile
donc c'est vrai que
nous sommes très nombreux mais aussi
faut approcher sa donc du fait que nous
n'avons pas beaucoup de structures
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées à la
martinique
donc nous venons compenser aussi ce
déficit en structures d'hébergement
notamment
oui mais alors là et fanny martinique ce
virage ambulatoire qu'il s'agit de
prendre vous le lier à la création tout
de même d'une maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire
c'est ça c'est à dire que c'est aussi un
concept qui est récent qui date d'une
dizaine d'années maximum il y en a très
peu à la martinique pourquoi parce que
pour faire du virage ambulatoire
c'est-à-dire que la prévention il faut
pas le faire seul il faut qu'on peut
faire avec d'autres professionnels de
telle sorte que nous ayons donc une idée
globale de la situation donc de chaque
personne
donc c'est pour cette raison c'est un
peu l'objectif des maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires
alors donc la profession d'infirmier
l'infirmière plus particulièrement dans
le secteur libéral connaît une évolution
et vous vous intéressez donc non
seulement à prendre le virage
ambulatoire mais vous dites rajouter
tout en prenant soin de soi en parlant
de 2,2 des infirmières et des infirmiers
justement un et vous mettez l'accent sur
le burn out des soignants c'est exact
c'est à dire qu'il faut prendre
conscience que beaucoup d'infirmières
doubt c ou épuisement professionnel ou
fait sur une référence absolue mans
puisque bon dont nous sommes dans une
situation nous devons commencer à
travailler très tôt beaucoup de
confrères commence dès 4 heures du matin
avec cette obligation d'acide d'assurer
ce que nous appelons la continuité des
soins c'est à dire un engagement est un
engagement s'il faut soigner tous les
jours nous allons soigner tous les jours
s'il faut soigner jusqu'à minuit le
faisons donc il est évident que
lorsqu'on travaille seul
on n'a pas forcément l'occasion
d'échanger avec les autres collègues et
on trouve aujourd'hui malheureusement
donc d affirmer qu'ils sont épuisés
d'autant que bon qu'il s'agit d'une
véritable petite entreprise donc on doit
pas gérer seulement des soins mais tout
ce qui va avec et qu'on puisse le plan
administratif fiscal et comptable
alors pour ce séminaire donc je le
rappelle donc ils commencent aujourd'hui
qui va se tenir à l'hôtel la batelière à
schoelcher jusqu'à demain justement dans
cet aspect prendre soin de soi pour les
personnels soignants pour
les infamies les pires vous avez fait
appel à une coach une coach personnel
donc il va intervenir au cours de ce
séminaire
voilà par exemple dès cet après midi
madame jean jacques
c'est sur le thème le succès est un
travail intérieur dit nous en quelques
mots oui c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que si on ne prend pas
conscience que si vous voulez la force
la plus importante c'est celle que nous
avons en nous tout d'abord c'est à dire
que considérer que nous exerçons un
métier mais pour pouvoir le faire dans
de bonnes conditions il faut être bien
soi même parce qu'il s'agit pas donc
d'arriver chez les patients et d'être
déjà complètement démotivée sans espoir
donc dans ce cadre là ça me paraît
important les choses de cette manière
puis un aspect aussi précisions sur les
skis encadre cette profession les textes
législatifs vous même vous allez
intervenir papa pas que vous mais sur la
convention nationale des infirmiers
libéraux qui a connu peut-être quelques
évolutions quelques modifications voilà
en gros donc sur l'actualité législative
quoi il s'agit donc de nouvel avenant
qui se rajoute à notre convention
nationale des infirmiers quelque chose
qui va de notre point de vue
révolutionner notre exercice libéral
avec d'une de nouveaux actes qui sont
ajoutés à notre nomenclature ses adieux
que donner plus de moyens aux infirmiers
libéraux pour pouvoir travailler mais
avant tout il faut que les infirmiers
libéraux maîtrise bien ce qui est
nouveau et c'est pour cette raison que
nous les invitons avec nos différents
partenaires à discuter à échanger alors
pour conclure jean marie clovis
président d'honneur de la fnb martinique
que syndicats donc deux infirmiers
finissent la fédération nationale des
infirmiers infirmiers j'ai vu dans votre
séminaire une intervention dans le
programme consacré aux coups de gueule
des auditeurs ah oui ça nous intéresse
nous oui c'est oui alors attendez je
précise une chose avec le psychologue
monsieur galvan voilà bien connu et puis
un autre anthropologue et psychanalyste
donc faire face à la pression faite par
l'opinion publique
alors en quoi ça vous concerne vous
infirmiers libéraux nous sommes très
décriée est malgré tout bon évidemment
c'est pas quelque chose de majoritaire
mais souvent on entend des coups de
gueule qui avec une grosse critique sur
l'exercice la pratique de l'exercice
libéral infirmiers et nous trouvons ça
beau
quelquefois peut-être justifie peut-être
justifiée certainement mémo cible des
critiques
par méconnaissance de notre profession
parce qu'on a on est convaincu
aujourd'hui que l'infirmier lorsqu'il
arrive il doit tout faire et que la
famille peut totalement se désengager
c'est pas du tout ça au contraire c'est
une aide que nous apportons et nous
demandons plus d'engagement donc de la
part de lits dans pas pour nous mais
pour le malade parce que si on est noir
le malade de sa famille évidemment il
n'ya pas que l'aspect physique qui a
l'aspect psychologique est en gros vous
êtes là pour soigner mais pas pour
remplacer l'accompagnement de la famille
ou de poudre proches
exactement et ça ce n'est pas très bien
compris de la part d'organismes
donc pour conclure donc voila vous
proposé aux infirmiers d'être heureux
mais tout en prenant soin de soi pour
offrir une qualité de son exceptionnelle
aux patients on peut résumer ainsi c'est
bien conclu merci jean marie clovis
d'être dense à oka dit ce matin enfin
d'avoir été dans sa aux cadis bonne
journée on se retrouve demain
qu'est ce qui se passe federica il ya un
souci je regardais leur simplement
s'était fait bientôt
j'appréciais les propos de votre éviter
je regardais également les commentaires
sur le chat on reconnaît la qualité de
son travail
d'accord on dira encore quelques mots
durs à des stands comment ça se présente
pour il nous avons effectivement
d'infirmiers et d'infirmières si venir
s'ils le souhaitent de venir arracher
deux mois parce que nous avons donc des
partenaires
à la fois sur le plan je dirais
comptable c'est à dire qu'on allait
battre mais aussi sur le plan technique
même des soins infirmiers on aura donc
ceux qui travaillent régulièrement avec
nous qu'ils sont donc sur les stands
pour donner encore plus d'explications
parce que nous avons cette obligation de
mettre à jour nos connaissances et si
l'occasion aussi pour les professionnels
donc d'être informé des nouveautés sur
sur ce qui se passe dans le métier voilà
très bien merci bonne journée
merci bertrand carouge qu'on retrouve
demain à 7h18 et puisqu'on parle des
infirmiers un grand bonjour à sidonie ou
sidonie donc c'est la fête aujourd'hui
et l'infirmière justement qui fait super
bien mon travail qui est adorable qui
s'appelle sidonie donc on va lui dédier
voilà ce petit bonjour
et puisqu'on à malte en bas moi je vous
lis ce qui est très sympathique et
dévoué vous êtes occupé d'une maman
chérie que vous appréciez énormément
c'est le témoignage d'une auditrice qui
vous suit actuellement sur la page
youtube l'opinion publique m6 et
infirmiers libéraux
l'application est bien sûr qu'on est
conscient du superbe travail que vous
faites auprès des patients merci en tout
cas et beaucoup de courage à tout le
personnel d'ailleurs hospitalier ceux
qui sont libéraux mais également à
l'hôpital bien sûr tout ce qu'ils sont
par les infirmiers mais les aides
soignants également qui font un travail
extraordinaire bon les médecins et
compagnie bien sûr merci d'être là
répandue et dans des conditions parfois
très difficiles
pas toujours évident effectivement